salut à tous aujourd'hui petite session
de pêche à leyment au bord du canal du
midi et surtout deux beau matos à tester
donc avant tout le barbarian way le
meilleur est vendu voilà le plus
puissant donc 1600 kg on espère faire de
belles trouvailles avec ça ça va être
intéressant on pourra repasser sur des
spots déjà fait ouais et recommencer en
fait à nouveau vous le montre la
regarder cette beauté avant qu'elle soit
rayé magnifique avec la cage de
protection toujours un maison de la
détection pour ce matos là et en plus de
ça on a les vertes magnetar donc veste
chauffante avec des batteries lithium
donc à style matin en sorte de l'hiver
donc on en a vraiment besoin il fait
froid pour la pêche a lancé par faire ce
qu'ils veulent se fournir chez maison de
la détection il ya le code promo
pêcheurs de trésors donc comme le nom de
la chaîne sans accent coutou colère
majuscule donc ça vous donne 5 % sur
toute la boutique profitez-en
comme on est un peu jalouse partager le
barrage françois faire une heure chacun
parce que bon le deuxième c'est un beast
1 c'est très bien aussi
mais le var 20 ça reste le meilleur
aimant du monde pas dans l'oural à aller
mais ça marche très bien
on est au chaud je sens quelque chose là
j'ai un gros truc
o o des outils ça peut commencer un
sergent un an il est en bonne et en
sicile en bon état ouais c'est cool hein
il est nickel
les eaux qui capte toujours plaisir
toujours un petit peu un petit peu
triste de sauter dans l'eau un aimant si
beau si brillante mais c'est comme ça
ou bien
au plafond ou d'un portail non sympa
sans nous voguons qu'est ce que c'est
comme quoi il ya vraiment des gros trucs
gros tubes we la tranche pas très bien
comment ça fait
et bien pendant le vide et les tubes que
tu mets dans les centrales nucléaires à
vous trois tirs de céline et de siebel
accroche qui peut moi aussi j'ai quelque
chose peut-être l'autre partie en tout
ce qui est encore web belle paire de
ciseaux ah oui c'est vraiment les
anciens ciseaux à 7 je pense que ça peut
se restaurer une bombe on te laissera
faire faudra tenter
franchement cette veste impeccable je
suis vitesse deux super puissances à
l'épée nouvelle entrée normale mais peut
mieux faire
gros truc ça alors
ah oui plein de trucs en fait ok c'est
lourd des jeunes des marchands de
bonnets ou le séjour
ouais ça va quand même être important de
tirer bien loin pour voir ce que les
gens ont pu jeter du pont a l'air bien
vide
il est ouvert et les ouvert ça tu peux
casser et caché des armes dans sa web à
faire tout le tour ouais
c'est quoi oui oui vélo un vélo et moi
j'ai fait une belle passe du coup tu as
un gros truc
alex part à la nage à la nage va le
chercher à la nage
et puis on
un bidon watts battant africain patois
[Applaudissements]
voix et jaloux voulait aller au traité
c'est quoi conduire à la parole il se
vide là
bien joué bon voilà pour le bidon
malheureusement il était ouvert ça
n'aurait pas été la même histoire il est
encore utilisable incident et il n'y a
pas de fuite en dirait avoir alors ce
qu'on peut faire avec ça la pêche
continue
c'est rempli de merde ici
joli c'est loin avant toute chose c'est
fou ce barbare 6 1 ouais ouais du plomb
ça accroche pas mais je le chante tu
arrives que j'ai subitement tout terrain
y
elle accorde à ses prises à une branche
[ __ ] mais c'était peut-être une
branche depuis le début de mois mais si
c'était la branche grid uranais pense
que c'était ça
alors oui je voulais plus loin
[Applaudissements]
secousses à un radiateur vraiment
n'importe quoi
les noms des raisins si je suis pas loin
à sa mort m
sabrina temps ok moi j'ai déjà fait un
ancien mois à il est sympa qu'est ce que
tu nous fais deux bouts avec ce nouveau
une chaise un métier ça allait avec la
table 1 c'est une chaise de pêcheurs ça
le bateau du coin ah oui peut-être pas
tout neuf on va écouter le barbare a
tenu ses promesses sur un spot déjà fait
ça arrête pas s'arrête pas vraiment
c'est comme si en fait on avait on avait
recommencé la pêche aliments nous ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va tout
nettoyer on va on va charger la voiture
on vous montrera une petite petite vue
du coffre et surtout on va essayer
d'utiliser par fabienne despot avec le
plus intéressant peut-être qu'on a déjà
fait ou qu'on n'a pas encore fait mais
qui vont être un peu plus riches spot de
criminels ouais donc voici le résultat
de cette session de pêche
donc voilà énormément de ferraille